E aí
[Música]
Olá eu sou o Caçula de cinco filhos
quatro homens e uma mulher mas apesar de
termos uma família grande lá em casa
ninguém aprendeu a demonstrar
sentimentos via contato físico ou
palavras como por exemplo dar um abraço
antes de se pedir para uma viagem ou
dizer eu te amo em momentos especiais
meu pai cresceu em uma família assim o
que provavelmente contribuiu e muito
para reprodução desse tipo de relação lá
em casa por outro lado desde muito novo
a maior e mais frequente demonstração de
amor do meu pai por mim foi via
incentivo e esforço para que eu fizesse
algum tipo de esporte ou exercício
físico quando eu tinha 7 anos ele me
colocou em uma Escolinha de Futebol do
bairro e após um ano eu consegui fazer
apenas um Gol Ele percebeu que aquela
não era muito a minha praia então me
mudou para natação mas no entanto sem
muito
e ativa de que eu tivesse sucesso nas
competições simultaneamente ele me
ensinou a jogar peteca no quintal lá de
casa e me levava para Correr 3 vezes por
semana regularmente atividades que
fizeram parte da nossa relação durante a
maior parte da minha vida finalmente
passar a fase da natação meu pai me
levou para fazer um teste na equipe de
vôlei do clube dos oficiais da Polícia
Militar de Minas Gerais Clube pelo qual
competir durante toda minha adolescência
e que permitiu que eu ganhasse uma bolsa
de estudos integral no colégio Magno em
troca de competir representando o
colégio meu pai faleceu em julho deste
ano no dia do seu aniversário de 78 anos
enquanto praticava o seu esporte
favorito do momento andar de bicicleta e
o maior legado que ele me deixou foi a
paixão EA necessidade de sempre estar em
movimento
e o esporte permitiu que eu postasse
todo o ensino médio em uma escola
particular o que contribuiu de maneira
decisiva para que eu fosse aprovado no
vestibular em fisioterapia da UFMG em
2004 a época o segundo curso mais
concorrido hoje sou fisioterapeuta e
professor do mesmo curso na mesma
instituição de ensino e entender o
movimento humano exercício físico é
parte central da identidade da minha
profissão hoje como fisioterapeuta e
professor ensino uso e pesquiso sobre
como movimento humano pode ser utilizado
para tratar e prevenir lesões
músculo-esqueléticas a queixa mais comum
dos nossos pacientes é dor em alguma
parte do corpo que limita o impede de
fazer alguma atividade do dia a dia
o tradicional mente Qual é a solução
utilizada para esse tipo de problema
tomar anti-inflamatório ou analgésico
colocar gelo calor o choquinho' parar de
fazer aquilo que doi ou todas as opções
anteriores
é mas será que essa é a solução mais
adequada ou é apenas mais cômodo e não
exige que a gente repense hábito de vida
que são inadequados o que a ciência nos
mostra para pacientes com dor lombar por
exemplo permanecer em repouso no leito
tende a piorar o problema por outro lado
tentar continuar com as atividades do
dia-a-dia e fazer exercícios físicos
orientados por um profissional da saúde
é a forma de tratamento mais eficaz
e para pacientes com degeneração e dor
no joelho o fortalecimento de membros
inferiores ajuda a reduzir a intensidade
e frequência da dor e melhora a
capacidade desses pacientes de fazer
atividades simples como andar e levantar
de uma cadeira em pacientes com ruptura
do tendão do ombro o tratamento via
exercício físico é tão eficaz quanto a
cirurgia para reconstrução desses
tendões e por isso hoje em dia é a
primeira linha de tratamento já que não
apresenta os riscos ou efeitos adversos
de um procedimento cirúrgico
Olá você sabia que a maior parte das
articulações do seu corpo só são
lubrificados quando vocês movimentam
movimento é o óleo das suas engrenagens
e o que você faz ou deixa de fazer com
seu corpo definir a capacidade do seu
corpo de lidar ou não com as demandas do
seu dia a dia
e dessa forma exercício físico tem
vários benefícios por exemplo corredores
de rua apresentam músculos ossos
ligamentos e tendões mais fortes do que
indivíduos sedentários apesar disso no
Brasil hoje temos 47 por cento de
pessoas sedentárias o que nos Confere o
quinto lugar no ranking mundial dos
países mais sedentários somos o país
mais sedentários da América Latina e
entre adolescentes brasileiros de 11 a
17 anos o dado é ainda mais alarmante 84
por cento são sedentários o sedentarismo
custa ao Brasil 3,62 bilhões de dólares
anuais inevitavelmente à medida que
envelhecemos os nossos músculos ossos
ligamentos se tornam mais fracos e a
única forma de desacelerar esse processo
é mantendo uma
e fisicamente ativa os benefícios do
exercício vão além dos benefícios
físicos descritos até aqui eles têm
benefícios por exemplo sobre a saúde
mental praticar exercício libera
opióides endógenos como a endorfina o
que além de ajudar na melhora da dor
músculo-esquelética ajuda na melhora da
sensação de bem-estar e na qualidade de
sono e tem sido inclusive utilizado como
tratamento adjuvante para condições por
exemplo como depressão ou ansiedade
evidências demonstram que fazer
exercício físico melhora a sua
capacidade cognitiva e obviamente a sua
capacidade cardiorrespiratória
a manter uma Vida Ativa é a melhor forma
de garantir e de prevenir lesões e ter
uma vida livre de comorbidades
e dessa forma a prática de exercícios
físicos deve ser encarada não apenas
como tratamento mas como promoção de
saúde que mais pessoas possam ter uma
vida como a do meu pai ativa e
independente até o seu final levarei a
prática de exercícios físicos como os
seus maiores legados e demonstração de
amor por mim muito obrigado